well the website eventbrite is a
seemingly straightforward and innocuous
non-political it would seem it's a
service where users can simply
manage and promote events or find events
that others have organized and that they
want to attend
as the website's twitter bio puts it
eventbrite is quote a global platform
that allows anyone to create share find
and attend events
that fuel their passions
well as it turns out maybe not anyone
actually turning point usa is planning a
screening of my film what is a woman
which uh the screening is supposed to be
this coming tuesday september 13th
at west kentucky university
they had used eventbrite's platform to
promote the screening but soon after
posting the event to the site they
received an email informing them that
the page had been removed for violating
the company's hate speech policies now
reading from the daily wire report on
this says an email from the company said
quote we encourage our organizers to
express their views and gather for a
chosen purpose as long as it's done in a
way that doesn't violate our legal terms
we do not permit events content or
creators that promote or encourage hate
violence or harassment towards others
and or oneself
the uh notice of
and or ones
that
that permit and encourage
violence and harassment against oneself
okay so you can't harass yourself or
other people and have an event
event they're saying the notice of
removal went on to say that the event
expresses views that are in violation of
the company's community guidelines and
terms of service
next the platform trust and safety team
advised that the event would be removed
the community guidelines for eventbrite
further promised that they are
quote committed to providing a safe
inclusive and respectful platform for
the organization discovery of live
events specifically prohibited content
includes hateful or dangerous content or
events that discriminate against or
threaten any societal group or encourage
violence the section specifies content
cannot be hate speech hateful ideologies
and hateful activities that incite
encourage or engage in violence
intimidation disparagement harassment or
threats targeting an individual or group
based on their actual or perceived race
ethnicity religion national origin
immigration status gender identity
sexual orientation disability age or
veteran status
now of course
my film uh which you know if you've seen
it and if you haven't seen it yet go to
what is a woman dot com and uh rectify
that situation immediately but you know
that my film does none of those things
there is nothing in the film that could
be remotely construed as incitement
or as a call to violence in fact
nearly the entire run time
consists of me simply walking around
and asking people questions that's
almost the whole film
the film actually provides a platform to
many trans people
and many professionals in the so-called
gender affirming industry
i give them a platform i give them a
chance to speak i put a camera in front
of them
now the fact that those professionals
embarrass themselves and collapse under
the most basic line of questioning it's
not my fault
nor does it make the movie a terrorist
act
or an act of incitement
i gave them a chance the whole movie is
me giving them a chance if they were not
able to take advantage of that
opportunity that's on them not on me
but at any rate this is all irrelevant
eventbrite claims that it's a
quote-unquote global platform for quote
unquote anyone to quote unquote create
share and attend events
so how does my movie fall outside of
that purview
would seem like a reasonable question
and yet the company refuses to answer it
we've asked them for clarification both
publicly and privately and so far been
simply ignored
this is the way it goes right
they won't even they they make a a
dramatic declaration saying that this
hit film is hate speech
and then when you ask well can you
explain that how is it hate speech
nothing no explanation
now any far-fetched hope that this
removal was a mistake you know
um as sometimes you you uh these sorts
of things happen with the with um
the big tech platforms someone's kicked
off or suspended and then they say oh it
was a mistake now when they say it's a
mistake it usually means that there was
one kind of rogue low-level employee who
just took it upon themselves to ban
somebody and then the higher-ups find
out about it and they correct it because
they don't want to deal with it and then
they say it was a mistake
any hope that that might happen here has
been dashed as more people have come out
of the woodwork announcing
that their own what is a woman screening
events have also been banned
apparently this has been happening for
several weeks now at least
the wake county republican party planned
a screening of the film back in july
only to have it removed from eventbrite
for violating its hate speech policies
supposedly there's a man named mark
early who sent me a screenshot of the
message that he got
when he tried to post an invitation for
his what is a woman movie night it was
taken down for allegedly running afoul
of the community guidelines
and then maybe most absurd of all
there's a group called no left turn in
education
and they had their own screening planned
for later this month
now in their case
they were planning to screen the movie
and host a discussion about it
afterwards
and a trans-identified person by the
name of sarah higdon had been scheduled
to speak at the event
and yet still the whole thing was deemed
hate speech so to be clear
a movie featuring trans people
followed by a discussion with trans
people is forbidden
because it encourages violence
presumably against trans people
meanwhile as one of the biggest
documentaries of the year has been
deemed too outrageous and controversial
for
this platform
they still will happily provide a forum
for all age drag shows
now you could go to eventbrite right now
and search for what is a woman on the
site and you're not going to find
anything except maybe some broken links
where events had been planned and then
were taken down but if you search for
events that bring drag queens
and children together
you'll find many results for example
there's an upcoming all ages drag show
in saint cloud and then there's the
union county children's drag story hour
and there's the drag queen story hour
with lil hot mess in seattle and many
other similar events
so that's allowed
but not
a film a documentary
one of the most talked about and widely
viewed of the year
now when you uh
actually let me correct myself it's not
one of the most talked about
documentaries of the year it is the most
talked about one
now when you
hear about this sort of thing
as a conservative and and i think we all
have this temptation that you hear this
and you shrug your shoulders and you say
well that's how it goes of course
they're going to ban the movie what did
you expect
and that reaction is understandable to a
certain extent
but we shouldn't become so jaded that we
fail to notice the considerable
escalation happening in our culture
right now
the effort to push conservatives
out to the margins to demonize and
stigmatize us
these efforts have reached a new level
in recent weeks and this is not
something we should take for granted or
just passively accept on the grounds
that it's inevitable
a few weeks weeks ago we were being
labeled as literal terrorists for
talking about the medical procedures
children's hospitals are inflicting on
kids just to talk about it is terrorism
then of course a major podcast
conference apologizes for allowing ben
shapiro to appear claiming that his very
physical presence causes harm
and then as you know the president
united states appears in ominous red
lighting to warn that uh people who
disagree with him politically are
dangerous extremists and threats to
our very way of life our democratic
system
and now we have a major event organizing
website that has declared a hit film
hate speech and banned it from its
platform without further explanation
now
the good news
about the eventbrite situation however
is that we can actually do something
about it
we can't stop biden from calling us all
terrorists until it's you know we at
least we can't stop him now when it's
time to vote him out of office we can do
that
but um
we have direct control and power here
we can
let companies like eventbrite
we can let them know that discriminating
against conservatives is not acceptable
if if all of us stopped using the
platform okay when i say all of us
anyone who's
if if you're a conservative or even if
you're not but you you you you still
claim to believe in free speech you
don't like the idea of big tech
platforms centering people if you're in
that category and that's millions of
people
if we actually used the leverage that
our numbers afford us
then we would have some power here
i mean a lot of these companies would
almost certainly back off because they
would have to
the problem though is that conservatives
for whatever reason are usually loathed
to use that kind of leverage and then
after refusing to use it
they become fatalistic and they say well
we don't have the leverage well no it's
not that we don't have it so we don't
use it
and that's on us if we don't use it
i mean what reason is there what what
good reason is there
for any of us to use eventbrite ever
again
unless they correct this what they're
doing here and apologize for it
if they don't they've made it clear
they hate you they don't want your
business
and yet if history is any indication
many conservatives will just say well
you know i'll give you my business
anyway even if you hate me you don't
want it
here take my money please take it
if we start using the leverage that we
have
then we can correct a lot of things
that right now we think cannot be
corrected one other point um
i would have
little complaint about eventbrite or any
of these other platforms that silence
conservative voices if they were honest
about it okay this is an important point
if eventbrite came out and just said hey
look we're a left-wing company we're
only interested in promoting left-wing
events that's what we do that's our
business
and this is why we exist we exist to
promote uh drag shows and that sort of
thing and that's that's our that's our
deal
now if they said that
i mean i wouldn't agree with it
morally i don't agree with anyone
organizing a drag show or anything like
that but if they said that and they said
that you know
they only want to cater to half of the
available market
well
that's their business that's their
decision i suppose
but the problem here the real problem is
that they're not being honest about it
it's an issue not just of silencing
voices but of outright fraud
because they claim to be a platform for
anyone
but they aren't it's a ruse it's a ploy
and then when it comes time to
banish someone to the hinterlands rather
than admitting that it's a political and
ideological decision they instead make
defamatory accusations about hate speech
and incitement
that's the problem that's what makes it
also especially outrageous
and now it's up to us to decide
whether we're going to start holding
these companies accountable
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there